do you know if there was any thought
put into who you guys played in season
one and then who you were
cast as in season two was there any like
specific
choice to really shake things up for any
one person
i think simon really wanted to flip the
kind of
um status of dan
and steve especially i think like
the highest possible status of god to
the lowest possible status of [ __ ]
shuffler
i think that really kind of like flipped
it i think for my character
it did feel like there was a sort of
common thread i felt like
in both seasons i was kind of the
audience's weigh-in
sort of um a little bit ahead of her
time
and um sort of reacting to the broken
world around her that's a that's a very
accurate description there
so given that you guys were picked up
for season three
yay i'm very excited do you want to
continue that threat in season three or
are you hoping that you get the
opportunity to do something like
completely different
i am i am hoping to do something a
little different this season
and i think from what i've heard it will
be a little like i think
um yeah we're sort of mixing it up
on on many levels for this season so
um i'm really excited to see what what
they come up with